depuis plusieurs mois un robot facilite
le travail des chirurgiens à l'hôpital
andré mignot du chesnay rocancourt da
26-10 c'est son nom à quatre bras
articulé qui contrôle les instruments
chirurgicaux
il est utilisé en urologie en chirurgie
digestive et en gynécologie
ici on placer vos têtes avec deux écrans
qui nous permet d'avoir la vision en 3d
il y à de drastiques qui nous permettent
de contrôler le déplacement des bras du
robot et l'articulation de l'extrémité
de l'instrument on appelle ça un robot
mais il est bien évident qu'il ne
travaille pas seul il est un outil
ultime pour augmenter le geste du
chirurgien ça améliore les processus
pour des interventions que l'on réalisé
auparavant sous coelioscopie en fait il
ya moyen de faire de la télé ce copie en
tenant soi même les instruments et c'est
ce qu'on fait depuis une trentaine
d'années et puis les robots sont arrivés
ils ce sont les bras du robot qui vont
tenir les instruments vous avez toujours
une position ergonomique vous êtes bien
installé le dos bien droit les mains qui
sont reposés sur cet appui là et ça vous
permet d'avoir une position confortable
pendant toute la durée de l'opération
donc ça va aider votre qualité de votre
geste les gestes sont ensuite légèrement
démultiplier et les mouvements vous
faites ici à l'extérieur sont finalement
plus ample que ceux qui vont être à
l'intérieur et ça vous permet d'avoir
comme ça plus de précisions le robot
permet également un meilleur confort
pour les patients l'instrument on va
bouger autour d'un point fixe ici au
niveau de la paroi abdominale avec très
peu de tension sur la parabole
musculaire ce qui permet de diminuer les
douleurs post opératoires du patient une
diminution de la durée d'hospitalisation
à la passion sur plutôt parce qu'il va
plus vite mieux
mais également ça diminue les
saignements au cours de l'intervention
avec une vingtaine d'opérations
effectuées depuis son arrivée en mars
dernier da vinci 10 est un nouvel outil
qu'il faut apprendre à apprivoiser les
formations se font de différentes façons
d'abord sur le simulateur donc c'est à
dire que c'est une sorte de logiciel une
sorte de jeu vidéo vous allez commencer
à apprendre la manipulation des
instruments la manipulation de la caméra
vous avez différentes formations de
différents niveaux avec du coup des
rencontres d'experts et puis des
exercices l'objectif de l'hôpital et de
conduire 400 opérations par an toutes
spécialités confondues l'hôpital andré
mignot est le premier hôpital public des
yvelines à obtenir ce robot le
département à participer à son
financement à hauteur de 1,4 million
d'euros